[Musica]
[Applauso]
Buonasera a tutti stamattina sono andato
in campo che ho questa fortuna
chiaramente lavorando nelle mele ho
raccolto una mela per voi e ogni volta
che raccolgo una mela Adesso ve la
faccio vedere internet l'ho tagliata
prima chiaramente c'è sempre un botanico
che mi dice guarda che non è un vero
frutto Ma la mela è un falso frutto
almeno botanicamente qual è il vero
frutto della mela e questa parte qui
interna che è il torsolo Che tristezza
direte Ma perché la mela si è evoluta
così nel tempo e lo vediamo da questo
grafico qui vediamo che la mela non è
nata in Europa è nata
nell'asia centrale in una zona che è
stata Rosignano il Kazakistan e pian
pianino ha camminato attraverso la via
della seta quindi questo vedete che si
ripercuota anche nella mela questa via
della seta ma non Chiaramente la mela
non ha le gambe quindi sono stati degli
animali soprattutto quadrupedi che
ulteriormente si alimentavano della mela
perché contiene Chiaramente deve essere
sostanza fra cui i carboidrati e quindi
nel tempo La mela è passata quindi
dall'Asia centrale arrivati in Caucaso
si è incrociato col malus orientalis e
poi dopo finalmente arrivate in Europa
in consandosi col malus silvestris ed è
diventata Mela ma questa grafico mi
serve per dire una cosa che per noi è
molto importante soprattutto in un'epoca
di cambiamenti climatici è necessario
salvare salvaguardare la biodiversità la
biodiversità sta in tutte queste specie
selvatiche quindi dove c'è l'origine
appunto dell'evoluzione della mela
Bon cos'è che facciamo quindi vediamo La
mela la sua origine Come si è evoluta
noi Agricoltori Cosa facciamo per noi
un'operazione molto importante è
l'impollinazione
l'impollinazione avviene all'interno per
esempio del territorio Trentino
Considerate che la mela una delle due
culture agrarie molto importanti cioè il
melo e poi c'è la vita e queste sono le
due culture principali
di medici ce ne saranno all'incirca mal
contatti circa 35 milioni di alberi in
Trentino tra cui 25 milioni sono nella
Val di nonno per effettuare
l'impollinazione cosa Cos'è che fanno
gli agricoltori alternano varietà
diverse perché così riescono a combinare
bene il polline e utilizzano per fare
l'impollinazione le api quindi vuol dire
che ci sono apicoltori trentini che
portano le loro armi però ci sono armi
che vengono anche da fuori regione
quelli che si chiamano gli apicoltori
che girano attraverso mettono le anime
nei camioncini vengono a noi fanno tutto
l'operazione di impollinazione
tendenzialmente a questa operazione è
un'operazione che avviene in
collaborazione tra gli agricoltori che
hanno il servizio di impollinazione e
gli apicoltori che finita l'impegnazione
se ne vanno via con il miele quindi si
vede che questa è proprio è una
caratteristica molto naturale di
simbiosi quasi mutualistica vi faccio
vedere le api perché noi naturalmente
come frutticoltori è assolutamente
necessario
proteggere e salvaguardare le api se non
si ha l'impollinazione non si formano i
semi e se non si formano i semi non si
forma neanche il frutto quindi abbiamo
le api ma abbiamo anche tanti insetti
che visitano i nostri frutteti per
esempio in questo caso abbiamo un
sirfide che è un dittero Quindi è una
mosca che si traveste da
ape o da vespe Ma infatti effettivamente
non è pericoloso si chiama In termine
mimetismo battesiano quindi altra cosa
che dobbiamo proteggere Quindi durante
importante tutto il periodo
dell'impollinazione sono anche queste
specie
di insetti quindi frutto falso ma a me
non piace tanto chiamarlo frutto faccia
a un certo punto della storia
dell'umanità la mela viene considerato
come frutto proibito ma effettivamente
così la mela è il frutto proibito No
questa è una fake news naturalmente
Adamo ed Eva Quindi l'obiettivo del
libro della Genesi era di dare la colpa
all'uomo non tanto a uno specifico
frutto ma dal basso Medioevo in avanti
al Rinascimento vediamo
la mela di dipinta dipinta in tanti in
tante intanto forme d'arte
e molto probabilmente questo frutto
proibito da quell'epoca in cui
effettivamente è diventato un frutto
molto popolare tra l'altro se lo
troviamo in leggende
Guglielmo Tell ce lo troviamo in fiabe
Biancaneve e la mela avvelenata di
Biancaneve lo troviamo anche vogliamo
nella nella fisica per esempio quindi
Isaac Newton la mela che cade
ce lo troviamo anche nei computer Sapete
bene la storia
di una società che produce computer ma
produce anche telefoni Infatti si parla
sempre di melafonino in quel caso lì
però perché in questo caso Steve Jobs ha
scelto la mela oltre che essere un
appassionato anche coltivatore e
raccoglitore di mele sapeva che la mela
era un frutto molto popolare Quindi lui
cercava di trovare anche un prodotto
molto popolare quindi computer molto
popolare per il pubblico e ha scelto la
mela quindi una mela morsicata
mela morsicata Questa è un'attività che
facciamo noi quando scegliamo nuove
varietà di mele
noi usiamo una tecnica che si chiama
analisi sensoriale praticamente usiamo
delle persone che vengono addestrate per
riconoscere i sensi Quindi le sensazioni
che dà mordendo una mela o un pezzo di
mela facciamo praticamente l'opposto di
quello che fanno i grandi cuochi i
grandi cuochi prendono gli ingredienti
le trasformazioni e mettono insieme
tutto perché sanno benissimo
i cuochi come se abbiamo bene noi che è
importantissima quando si deve produrre
una mela buona da mangiare la percezione
multisensoriale trovare l'equilibrio tra
i diversi sensi vedete per esempio
nell'immagine l'esperienza che sa a
livello della parte esterna del cervello
e il piacere che campi internamente
anche noi Nelle nuove varietà di meno
cerchiamo questo equilibrio per esempio
abbiamo scoperto in questi anni che una
caratteristica molto importante che non
avevamo considerato una decina di anni
fa Ma che è ritornato molto in House che
la croccantezza della mela la
croccantezza della mela perché la
croccantezza produce rumore quindi va a
stimolare l'udito per esempio questa è
una varietà che adesso Tra una decina di
giorni verrà raccolta qua in Val di Non
che si chiama suitango che tra l'altro è
una mela molto rumorosa e quindi ha
ottenuto anche
per esempio il guinness dei primati come
la Mela più rumorosa al mondo qui
vediamo un'immagine poi abbiamo capito
anche il perché la suitango Quindi
questa mela è così rumorosa perché ha
una particolare conformazione delle
cellule sono molto irregolari hanno
dimensioni diverse anche di spazi
intercellulari quelli che vedete in nero
sono molto irregolare così quando si
morde quando si applica una forza
praticamente esplode e quindi produce
rumore quindi la mele buona la mele
Popolare È buona però anche fa bene fa
bene alla salute c'è un detto che
direi conosciuto da tutti voi che è
stato creato da un da un medico inglese
una meglio al giorno toglie il medico di
torno Anche noi ci siamo chiesti Ma è
vero che una mela al giorno toglie il
medico di torno Effettivamente sì
Considerate che la mela come tanta altra
frutta la maggior parte la composizione
È acqua me la circa 82 85% d'acqua
abbiamo visto in questi anni che ci sono
due composti Due tipologie di composti
molto importanti nella mela sono le
fibre e i polifenoli che vanno incidere
positivamente sul microbiota intestinale
che è un nuovo terminologia Per una
volta si parlava di flora intestinale e
questo è molto importante per il nostro
benessere psicofisi quindi il consiglio
è proprio di mangiare una ma direi
meglio due mele al giorno naturalmente
poi altri composti Ma questi sono
contenuti in tante altre frutta e
verdura come la vitamina G proteine
carboidrati minerali come calcio
potassio e magnesio Poi c'è anche ma
tutto Questo spiega il fatto che la mela
toglie il medico di torno abbiamo
guardato dentro attraverso una
collaborazione col Dipartimento di
Medicina traslazionale dell'università
di Ferrara abbiamo incominciato a capire
se la mela produce delle vescicole
extracellulari che è un sistema che
viene utilizzato in natura per
comunicare tra le cellule Tra l'altro
queste vescicole extracellulari ha una
hanno una conformazione molto
caratteristica vedete che sono a una
doppia membrana fosfolipidi che sono
delle palline molto molto piccole a
livello nanometrico e contengono sono
piccoli sequenze di mrna
Assomiglia molto al vaccino al covip
hanno copiato un po' quello che succede
già in natura Quindi abbiamo estratto
queste biciclette extracellulari
dalle mele le abbiamo applicate per
esempio a delle cellule umane che vedete
dei film Basta Abbiamo visto come vedete
nei pallini rossi che le cellule umane
assorbono e quindi implementano le
vescicole Eccole cellulari di mela
Quindi c'è un un dialogo non possiamo
dire tra la mela e l'umano poi abbiamo
provato sono ancora delle ricerche che
sono in Corso il ruolo perché sapevamo
che la mela aveva questo ruolo
antinfiammatorio abbiamo provato
a trattare i macrofagi che sono una
parte del sistema immunitario sono molto
importanti quando devono intervenire per
uccidere le cellule malate e abbiamo
visto perché i necrologi sono due stati
Dottor Jekyll e Mister Hyde quando sono
in Dottor Jekyll anziché diminuire
l'infiammazione l'aumentano vedi casi
covid il Long covid quello che è
successo durante questi due ultimi anni
trattate con le nanos vescicole vegetali
hanno cambiato conformazione quindi sono
diventati sono diventati Mister Hyde
abbassando quindi il livello
antinfiammatorio quindi è sono ancora
delle ricerche in corso Dobbiamo capire
esattamente come avvengono
nell'assorbimenti Dove avvengono E
perché ma comunque abbiamo aggiunto un
qualcosa in più alle proprietà salutari
della mela quindi fibre polifenoli
attualmente si stanno studiando appunto
queste
micro vescicole vegetali speriamo Poi di
ottenere ulteriori risultati quindi
concludendo
parlando di Orizzonte abbiamo visto che
la mela è una mela Popolare fa bene e
buona il messaggio che vi volevo
lasciare era quello dell'inizio quindi
biodiversità salvaguardia delle api
quindi dobbiamo sempre di più sembra una
cosa banale alla coltivazione della mela
ma non lo è molto complessa osservare
capire e proteggere cioè una parola che
attualmente Per noi è molto importante
che
sostenibilità Grazie e buona sera